Speaker 1: All right, everybody, let's get
into the Friday mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
The emails will be reviewed.
They will be screened.
They will be.
We're going to do a lot.
We'll check them for bamboo fibers the way
that it was done in Arizona.
Everything will be done.
It's crazy what we do to these emails and
then I will read a few to you and respond,
we have wacky ones, we have productive ones.
We have SB.
We have people who are just angry with me.
We have all of it.
All right.
So let's just jump right into it.
First one comes today from Rick, who says
about the Trump conviction.
Rick says, Hi David, I'm wondering why lots
of people are demanding a Trump criminal conviction.
Nobody talking about something that seems
obvious to me.
Any jury is statistically bound to have at
least one Trump supporter in it, if not more.
One is all you need for a hung jury, so it's
all for nothing.
He would never be convicted of anything in
a jury trial.
What is your take, Richard in California?
Yes, I have said before.
Not only is there a political question here,
not only is there a question of there's so
many different issues with the idea of a Trump
trial, a Trump criminal trial, but how do
you even get a fair jury?
And we've been talking about last week, this
week in the context of the Kyle Rittenhouse
trial, and I told my story for my jury duty
experience and something very minor compared
to this about how hard it is to get competent
juries, even for minor things.
I don't know how you get a real a jury to
truly do what they are supposed to do when
it comes to a criminal trial with someone
like Donald Trump.
But I think it's a merely academic question.
As I've said before, I just don't think it's
going to happen, and I know people get mad
and say, David, you're making it less likely
that there will be a conviction when you say
that.
No, I don't think that that's the case at
all.
Or that the less likely there will even be
charges.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
All right.
Next one is from Ren Ren says.
I have jumped ship.
Pacman is MSM mean?
I guess they mean Pacman is mainstream media
narrative stance on these vaccines has put
me totally off.
Well to you.
I say Good sir.
Bye bye.
If you don't want to watch this show or listen
to this show, because of my view on vaccination,
we probably weren't meant for each other.
This was probably a relationship that, you
know, let's go with.
It's not you.
It's me.
It's not.
Let's let's go with that.
Also, another love letter.
This one's more more insidious.
This one's from Alex, Alex says.
Why won't you address Jewish supremacy?
I saw the title.
I said, Oh.
Alex writes, This is really ugly stuff, by
the way, you may want to get the kids out
of the room, Alex writes.
You want to call out white supremacy.
Fine, do it.
But what about Jewish supremacy?
Is it because you are Jewish and a supporter?
I am not anti Semitic at all.
But if you seriously think we're not on to
what's really going on here and who's really
in charge of this globalist plot?
Then you're wildly mistaken, at least Trump
tried to fight these globalist internationalist.
I should actually be using the Alex Jones
globalist, internationalist Trotskyites socialist
run like Obama, Trudeau, Mcbrown and the rest
of the Zio Beach Beach.
This is anti-Semitic.
And as I've told you before, I mean, listen,
at this point, I've explained this six ways
from Sunday, folks.
COVID conspiracies are drenched in anti-Semitism.
The whole concept of one world or shadow government
that there's a real government.
It's drenched in anti-Semitism.
It's just slathered, it's bathed.
It's sue vided in anti-Semitism.
This is a perfect example, and I don't know
if saying I'm not anti-Semitic, but is even
part of part of the insanity here, but it's
a very, very sick person.
But sadly, many people hear that and they
go, that person is not sick.
That's their politics, and I agree with them.
And that's.
It's a very, very scary thing, Paul wrote
in Paul Says David, is there anything stopping
President Biden from using an executive order
to eliminate the Electoral College?
It hasn't been needed since the invention
of the Telegraph back in 1861.
Why do we still use it?
Allow our president to be elected by popular
vote by the people, period.
Stop wasting taxpayers money on gerrymandering.
I'm looking forward to your response, Paul.
Well, so remember, gerrymandering is congressional
districts within states.
Usually when we talk about the effect of the
Electoral College on presidential, we don't
use the term gerrymandering, but I agree with
the sentiment completely.
The Electoral College should go.
I've explained why time after time after time,
however, there is something stopping Joe Biden
from eliminating it by executive order, which
is that you need.
I'm going.
I'm going by memory here to get rid of the
Electoral College you need.
I believe it is three quarters of the states
to do a constitutional convention.
Now, is it an two or two thirds of the House
and Senate?
Listen, Biden can't do it by himself, is the
point.
That being said, the most direct path to eliminating
the popular vote is something called the NPV.
I see the national popular vote interstate
compact, and this doesn't require anything
done federally.
It only requires states to pledge.
Instead of giving our electoral votes to whoever
wins our state, we will give our electoral
votes to whoever wins the national popular
vote.
So, so example, Oklahoma could say, no matter
how Oklahoma voters vote, if the Democratic
candidate wins the popular vote, we give our
votes to that candidate.
If the Republican candidate wins the national
popular vote, we will give our votes to that
candidate.
Every state has the right to decide how they
will give, how they will apportion electoral
votes.
And once you get enough states in total whose
electoral votes combine to be at least 270,
you have effectively eliminated the Electoral
College.
Okay.
I don't know that that's going to happen.
All right, here's what I have to admit this
is one of the strangest emails I've ever gotten.
This is someone who is furious that I mentioned
that we post content to Instagram.
Jeff wrote To me, Too much, David, too much,
David.
Dear David, you're my favorite political show
on YouTube.
But if you think I'm going to spend my time
going from YouTube to Instagram to Tik Tok
or whatever other social media, you're seriously
mistaken, young man.
OK.
You didn't use Young Man, but it felt appropriate.
You're a political commentator, not my life.
It's like you got stuck in Instagram.
You want to drag people to it for the hell
of it.
And I would bet that a lot of your viewers
feel the same way I do.
I'll see what you post to YouTube.
But as for the rest, I'm fine with missing
it, Jeff.
I love it.
No, no one has ever.
It's just I sometimes offhandedly say, Hey,
we're also posting stuff to Instagram.
Check it out if you want.
If you don't buy it by no means.
Jeff, I love that you.
I'm turning this around to make it a positive
thing.
You are putting a limit.
On how much time you're going to spend consuming
stuff on social media, I think it's fantastic.
These platforms are habit forming.
These platforms can suck you in.
I love what you're doing, Jeff.
You know what?
You tell me where your line is, my friend,
and it sounds like for you, it's YouTube.
I love it all full power to you, Lawrence
wrote to me, and Lauren said, Obviously, the
election in Virginia was rigged and this was
we.
I know who Lawrence is and this is satire,
and Lauren is a Lawrence is astutely pointing
out.
Um, Republicans, the new thing is, if you
lose, you say it was rigged.
They said many of them, even before the Virginia
election, Democrats are already trying to
rig it.
There was some state senator.
We looked at the clip last week.
We looked at it again on Monday, state senator
who said they're already rigging it.
Here's how they're doing it.
Glenn Youngkin one last Tuesday.
They never mentioned anything about fraud
or any rigging ever again.
And why is that?
Because it's not really about rigging.
It's about if we win, it's not rigged.
And if we lose, it is rigged.
That's fundamentally the only thing that it's
about.
And Lawrence is 110 percent correct.
Let's go to our next voicemail.
It's from Barbara.
Barbara responded to the not good results
in New Jersey and Virginia and in general
last Tuesday for Democrats.
By saying, David, if Democrats don't wake
up about wokeness, we will continue to lose
more.
Please read Woke Racism by John McWhorter.
McAuliffe was a disaster when he did not support
parents.
The school anger will only grow if Democrats
don't wake up about messaging.
You know, what's funny about this is McAuliffe
really wasn't a poster candidate.
And unfortunately, Barb won.
I hope I can call you Barb.
One of the saddest parts of this election
is Youngkin, one with lies about critical
race theory.
Critical race theory is a framework typically
taught or utilized in college, in law school,
etc.
It's not taught.
Now, the counterpoint that people are now
coming up with is, well, listen, it doesn't
matter if you teach critical race theory.
If teachers are, if it's the worldview of
a teacher, even if they're just teaching geography,
it's still going to destroy our kids.
Different argument and you've got to prove
that.
You've got to prove that because critical
race theory is just not being taught to kids
in Virginia.
And so unfortunately, I am not a woke slur
myself, and I've been critical of elements
of the left.
But this is this I think this is a little
off here, Barbara.
Unfortunately, Drew wrote in with a comment
on last week's show and said, David, you mentioned
New Jersey being a bad sign because of the
gap.
What I meant by that was the last New Jersey
gubernatorial was like a massive win for the
Democrat, and this was like barely a win for
the Democrat.
Drew says it's not necessarily a bad sign
because New Jersey voter participation is
very low in these elections, and the Democrats
have not held the gubernatorial seat in two
elections since 1976.
So in my book, this is actually a win for
Democrats because we broke a multi-decade
trend.
Yes.
As I mentioned, you can always find some way
to characterize a situation where it's less
bad.
I think this is the best, the most optimistic
interpretation, which is typically after Democrats
win, they then lose.
They just they straight up lose.
So rather than seeing it as, oh man, Democrats
won by a lot and now they barely won.
We should see it as Democrats won.
Normally they would lose if you go back to
1976 and Democrats won again.
So that is valid, that is valid.
And at a certain point, it sort of starts
to get into the level of you guys have seen
these.
If any of you watch sports, you know that
technology and statistics and machine learning
and all these different things
Speaker 3: have made it
Speaker 1: so that in almost any situation,
you can create a statistic that seems meaningful
in sports like, for example, you know, four
games played by Leo Messi in the southern
hemisphere between December and March, when
his team is leading going into the second
half, he scores a goal 50 percent of the time.
And then we would be.
Our heads are spinning and we're saying, but
that, wow, that's really interesting, but
is that is that at all relevant?
I'm not even really sure.
And then you can come up with that sounds
pretty good.
He's going to score a goal and say, you know,
four night games played in Latin America.
He very rarely scores goals in the second
half when his team is when his team is.
When you see the point we can interpret these
things and we have to find meaning in the
statistics, we have to find meaning in the
statistics and ultimately the results in 2022
are going to tell us exactly how disastrous
or not last week's elections were for Democrats
across the country.
I hope that you will get instant access to
today's bonus show by signing up on my website.
You can go to join Pacman dot com.
We really do depend on your support.
We have a staff here.
We have, you know, all of these different
expenses.
We do health care.
We do retirement.
We do all of these different things.
And I am able to be a better employer in great
part thanks to people who value and support
the work that we do.
So grab a subscription at join Packman dot
com and we will see you in mere moments on
today's bonus show.